good morning heck it's tuesday although
you wouldn't know it from watching the
last month of vlogbrothers videos there
are actually books other than the
anthropocene reviewed book and today i'd
like to tell you about my two favorite
books so far this year both of which as
it happens come out today
but first disclosure i know both these
authors i know a lot of authors and i
don't think that knowing someone affects
my opinion of their books much but
i do think it should be acknowledged
okay let's begin with how the word is
passed by clint smith who some of you
know from crash course black american
history this is a book about how the us
does
and doesn't reckon with the history of
slavery but it's also very much a book
about the present because smith is
looking at history through
present tense visits to tourist sites
from a visit to thomas jefferson's
estate monticello where jefferson
enslaved hundreds of people to a walking
tour of sites in new york city
associated with the slave trade
smith shows us how profoundly the
present is shaped by the past but he
also explores how the choices we make
today
about where to center historical
narratives end up shaping our
understanding of slavery and race and
poverty and much more
part of what makes this book so
brilliant is its both-handedness like it
is both a searching historical work and
a journalistic account of how these
historic sites operate today
it's both carefully researched and
lyrical i mean smith is a poet and the
sentences in this book just are
piercingly alive and it's both extremely
personal
it is the author's story and
extraordinarily sweeping it amplifies
lots of other voices both past and
present one such person is yvonne holden
who works at a plantation that centers
its tours around the experiences of
enslaved people and she notes in the
book that legacies are quote
not just the things we choose a lot of
them are things we don't choose
how the word is passed is about those
legacies and how they are at work today
and what happens when we grapple openly
with them
but it is also about what happens when
we construct false historical narratives
to
avoid having to confront those legacies
reading it i kept thinking about that
great alice walker line
all history is current my other favorite
book this year
is ashley c ford's somebody's daughter
some of you will know ashley from her
guest hosting of dear hank and john or
from her magazine writing but this
is her first book and wow
it's customary to describe books by
genre this is a memoir
and then by plot this is the story of a
young black girl living through
abuse and yearning for the presence of
her incarcerated father but i feel like
those descriptions sort of objectify or
depersonalize
the pain and love and particularity of
this book
somebody's daughter is so much more than
any summary of it could be so much more
wrenching
and haunting and beautiful and damning
and loving and everything else a book
can be
the writing sears and soars the
granularity of ford's memories and her
ability to share them
make for a reading experience i will
carry with me for the rest of my life
roxane gay wrote of ford's ability to
quote see people for who they are
without looking away
and i think that gift for
characterization is a big part of what
makes this book
so incredible but like all my favorite
books it is also about big themes
seen through an individual lens it's
about trauma
and family and race and also about how
big
systems affect human lives including the
ways that poverty and racism
harm children but honestly there is
nothing simple about somebody's daughter
and i really think that any attempt to
summarize it or even to tell you what i
love about it
only essentializes the unessentializable
what i can tell you is that the moment i
finished it i turned back to the first
page and started rereading it i am
43 years old and i have spent a big
chunk of those years reading
and i don't think i have ever
immediately reread a book before
both these books are so special i cannot
believe they come out on the same day
if you've read them let me know in
comments what you thought of them if
you're reading something else let us
know in comments what it is whether you
like it
because i'm looking for book
recommendations it's a big priority of
mine at the moment as it says on my 2021
vision board
read more books hank i'll see you on
friday